c'est l'histoire d'un examen qui
s'attirent beaucoup d'hostilité l'examen
du ministère de france c'est 2019 à son
groupe facebook
trente cinq mille membres en quelques
jours les raisons de la colère
l'intitulé de la question peut-on
s'adapter au changement climatique
beaucoup y voient une fatalité tout
sinon ton agir dire qu'il faut s'adapter
à la place d'agir dit mathilde des
ruisseaux à weiss s'est mal informé tous
les jeunes du québec ça encourage les
gens à baisser les bras la question
certains ont décidé d'ajouter un signe
pour dire leur mécontentement
on a vraiment mis un point bas pourrait
signifier à l'eau on est là on veut agir
c'est comme un cri du coeur pour nous on
n'a pas voulu amener ses dents longues
d'une accusation donc ouvert la main le
ministre de l'éducation a d'ailleurs été
interpellé sur la question pour moi qui
rédige les questions chaque été ses
exams et que les étudiants soient
mobilisés intéressé à agir concrètement
coûté sincèrement c'est formidable on
veut recevoir des actions
le ministère avait l'occasion étudie une
dizaine de milliers de jeunes de partout
au québec car espace d une semaine sur
les changements climatiques il sachs ont
conclu que nous peut faire pour les
ralentis mais au lieu de ça il est tout
de suite à l'aise sur les sujets d
comment plus adaptés comme s'il était
déjà trop tard
jean françois robert je vois au moins
une vertu dans cette polémique autour
d'une question
manifestement ils ont développé la
compétence de l'alimentation est ce que
solide et ce texte argumentatif ici
mathieu proche parent du canada montréal